Why do we learn?
What is it for?
It is for happiness
Happiness, what is this?
Is it to get into a good college or company,
and receive good compensation?
Is this what is considered as a happy life?
Not necessarily
A happy life, is to live it in your own way
You cannot learn it from someone else
It is something that you have to find with
your own will
For you to find it, you need an abundant amount
of knowledge and experience
And, you have to think with your own head
I founded a Math cram school for elementary
school students in 1993
My math classes are unique
I am a teacher by profession, but hate teaching
In reality, I don't teach my students
I call it the Theory of Teaching of Strength
I published this book through Discover in
I kept on thinking how I could make my students
smarter
I asked myself, if I explained it in a way
that is easy to understand and thorough would
this make the students smarter?
Not necessarily
If it would make them smarter, my job would
be very easy
When you explain it in this way, the students
start to have this illusion
That they understand, but they don't really
understand because they cannot answer it on
their own
When I was young, I loved to teach, I loved
it so much that I taught too much
These unlucky kids were not able to think
in their own head
That was my wrong doing, and I also think
it is a crime
I deeply regret this, and decided to turn
over a new leaf
So, how do I make the students smarter
I finally found the answer
The essence of studying math is to continuously
think
Addition, substraction, multiplication, division,
integer, fraction, minority
These are all of it
And all you need to do is match them together
There is no meaning in learning these matches
from anyone
It doesn't even make it fun or interesting
If you can answer the question, if you can't
answer the questions, it doesn't matter
If you can understand it, if you can't understand
them, it doesn't matter
You can't get the answer
You simply have to enjoy trial and error
In this way, the answer will come to you
Recently, I have had the chance to catch up
with my students in the past over drinks
Of course, everyone is of legal age
The graduates who I happen to reconnect with
are all enjoying life
When they were young, it is the same way they
enjoyed trial and error in my class
They enjoy the challenges in life
This gives me an extremely happy feeling
This is because, they are living proof that
my theory of education
"Teaching without teaching" has actually worked
the right way
By the way, do you know the puzzle that will
make you smart?
In this portion of this puzzle, this is called
the calculation block
IT is a puzzle where you calculate to solve
the problem
The calculation block's English name is "Ken
Ken"
It is on over 150 newspapers around the world
It is on the New York Times daily
In Japan, it is on the Yomiuri magazine bimonthly
It is also featured in the monthly publication
of Tokyo publishing's "Math for Middle School"
and "Math for High School"
I would
like to talk about when I created this puzzle
In the first 2 years
The first 2 years I started the cram school
I only held math classes for 4th to 5th grade
primary school students
There are actually 4 types of problems in
math
There are easy ones that are fun, easy ones
that are boring, hard ones that are fun, and
hard ones that are boring
I only make fun problems
Only fun problems make the students smart
The fun problems win the heart of the student
and never let go
There was an interesting event that occurred
that proved this
In March 11th 2011
There was a massive earthquake
It was an afternoon on a Friday
I was on the way home
The ground suddenly started moving, and it
was the biggest earthquake I had ever experienced
The next day and the day after the earthquake
held classes as usual
Not all transporation systems were back to
regular operation
But most of the students came to class
During the class, there were many after shocks
Back then, our class in Nihonbashi was on
the 12th floor of a 13 story pencil-thin building
At an intensity 2, we can very much feel the
shake
"Here it is!" we would shout, and a lot of
these intensity 2 and 3 after shocks would
come
I felt scared when I felt those earthquakes
But when I look at the students, none of them
would lift their head up
At first I thought "Despite the fear they
felt determined to work hard", but that wasn't
the case, they just didn't notice them
I have 4 classes, one for the 3rd grade, 4th
grade, 5th grade, and 6th grade
There are about 20 students in each class
In one class, we had after shocks many many
times
But no one, even once would lift their head
up to check what was going on
I was shocked, but I was impressed
But when you think about it, it isn't the
students that are extraordinary
Because they aren't chosen to participate
in the class
They weren't selected, actually anyone can
enroll
So, it is actual my study material that was
doing an excellent job
It greatly won over the children, even the
earthquakes they would not notice
It intensely attracted them, and with the
high concentration, they continued to think
I genuinely thought my materials were amazing
When I started the cram school, the first
2 years
I made most of the math problems from 4th
grade to 6th grade students
Right when I was thinking that I wanted to
do something new
I received requests from parents who had kids
in the 3rd grade
They asked me to start a class for 3rd graders
And I thought it for a week
Because I didn't really want 3rd grade students
to study math
At this age, their concept formation has not
progressed, and it would only confuse them
If they were to study, it should be something
than can relate to when they start studying
math in 4th grade
I started looking for study material that
would let them enjoy writing and deleting
Then I found a puzzle
In 1995, I started a class on puzzles for
3rd grade students
They rapidly became absorbed in the puzzles
And, were able to think thoroughly for a longer
period
I created different kinds of puzzles almost
everyday
But it wasn't enough
I wanted a puzzle that required the four rules
of arithmetic
What came out of this is in 2003, I started
making the Ken Ken blocks
What I created first was a 4 by 4 with only
addition problems
Next is a 9 by 9 with only addition problems
Then next I created a mix of addition and
subtraction, then multiplication and division
Then I went on to create puzzles that made
all four rules mixed, and with operators
I went on to create these math calculation
blocks
And for my final challenge, I wondered what
would happen
If I eliminated the operator from the puzzles
that had operators and a mix of all four rules
It became a very hard problem, but I was able
to form it
All of the challenges for a success, and I
was able to complete one world of Ken Ken
blocks
"I made it!"
I cried
In the middle of the night I was running around
the classroom
wondering if people always used to run around
like this.
I have created different kinds of puzzles
up to this point
This Ken Ken block is only one part of it
But it is a special puzzle
The calculation blocks would dramatically
increase the academic skills of the students
They dare not give up
They do not compromise
My educational theory "Teaching without teaching"
In this, the kids that continued to use their
heads
Went on to gain success in different fields
There are doctors, lawyers, bankers, professional
stock traders, scientists, and teachers
There is also a student that went into agriculture
There is also an artist
There is one that became a ballerina in a
famous Eurpean ballet company
She dances with the world as her stage
The Ken Ken puzzles boosts the happiness of
the students
This is the existence it has become
Recently, I have the opportunity to go out
for a drink with a first batch graduate of
the Ken Ken blocks
He studies medicine at a top level university
in Japan
Today he continues to focus on his future
and continues to work hard
I look forward to meeting other graduates
of the Ken Ken puzzles
The students are not the only one who benefited
from the Ken Ken blocks
I have also benefited from it
The Ken Kken blocks has made me famous
On December 10, 2006, I was featured in the
show "JOUNETSU - TAIRIKU"
It received tremendous response
And the Ken Ken blocks has made me rich
It sold so much
Currently, I have a class in Manhattan and
in Nakano, Tokyo
8 months out of a year I spend in Manhattan
And I spend the remaining 4 months in Tokyo
This lifestyle has become very exciting and
fun
Before moving to Manhattan
I was living a very blessed life in Tokyo
I had no reason to start anything new
Just by doing the same thing, I can continue
to live a fun life
But in 2013, there were 2 events that greatly
changed my way of thinking
My experience started with an E-Mail
In the past, I only had interest in
My classes and the students of my classes
The person who sent me the Email was from
a math teacher Melissa
from the American School of Paris
The Email read, In April, I will bring along
my students to go to Japan
Can I visit your class with my students?
I would like to let my students take your
classes
I heard that your class is close to Tokyo
station
I was surprised
At that time, I did not publicize the location
of my classroom
Even Japanese did not know where my class
room was
And, Melissa also understood my theory in
education
Then I thought about it for 1 week
I do not know how to speak English
And it still remains my deepest weakness until
this day
But as a result, I decided to take them in
It has undoubtedly become a great experience
This is for myself, and even for my visitors
Melissa and I exchanged Emails frequently
And after a new months, 3 teachers with 18
students came to Tokyo
The students were aged 14 to 16
For the first page, I prepared materials published
by Gakken
There were about 30 books on the table
And I told them "I will give you one book
each as a present, please pick one"
"But please pick wisely, you will be answering
the problems later"
They went on to peak into the content and
pick a puzzle that looked like they could
answer
Including 3 teachers, everyone held a book
and returned to their seats
Then I instructed "I will give you 50 minutes,
you can do whatever you want."
Everyone started solving the problems
No one gave up
Even Melissa was working on the questions
When I passed by her, she started talking
to me
She said "I cannot believe this"
"I have never seen these kids concentrate
for this long in solving problems."
I answered.
"That is the power of my study materials."
"Fun problems easily wins the hearts of the
student, and it does not let go."
The students from Paris said they wanted to
interact with Japanese students
So, I sent out an Email to the graduates
"There's this event, do you want to come?"
There were 17 graduates that came
The next stage was my new puzzle
It was a puzzle that no one has seen, and
it was a contest to solve them
3 top graduates were competing neck in neck
One of them won the contest
It was a very good match
Though the students from Paris did not win,
worked hard and continued to solve the problems
The next step was the one-on-one cultural
exchange
This is what we wanted to do the most
The students from paris would draw a number
Then would converse with the students one-on-one
It was the first time speaking to foreigners
For many of the graduates
The students from Paris would speak very slowly
and properly at the beginning
But after a couple of minutes they would go
back to their normal speed
Looking at this, I thought to myself "They
probably have no clue what the other is saying"
But I let them be
And after this, most of the graduates that
took part in the event went on to study abroad
The last stage was Karaoke
Everyone went to a Karaoke Box and sang only
one song
It was Carol King's "You've Got a Friend"
It is a beautiful song about a friend that's
somewhere far
But no one knew the song
We sent out the URL of the Youtube video beforehand
I told them to practice this 100 times because
we will be singing the song at the end of
the event
Everyone sang the loudest they can
And we sent them off to the station
This is most definetely one of the best days
in my life
This was the first time I held interest
In other students that weren't mine
After 5 days, Melissa sent me a heartfelt
Email
It read "During our visit to Japan, it was
the most memorable day we spent"
"I would like to thank you and your staff
from the bottom of our hearts"
After reading the Email, I thought
"All the American School students of the world,
come to Japan, I will let you have a good
time!"
That is what I thought
It was an eye opener
There were a couple of trendy looking girls
And I thought that these kids would not be
interested in my puzzles
Even they immersed themselves in the puzzle
I want more children from other countries
to experience my puzzles
That is what I thought
As much as possible I want to go to poor schools
And let them play the same puzzles
That is what I was thinking
After 1 month, since Melissa and the students
came to visit
I had the opportunity to visit Chiang Rai
in the northern part of Thailand
I thought many different things before going
there
I wanted to teach them how to solve and how
to make the Ken Ken puzzles
And I would tell them, "When you make 100
puzzles"
"I will bring them to the publisher, and publish
it as a book"
"I will then donate all of the royalty to
the school"
This is what was running in my head when I
went to Thailand
I held a 90 minute class for 5th and 6th grade
students
Before going there a lot of people gave negative
comments
"It is impossible, you cannot teach math"
I became very nervous
But when I went into the classroom, and started
to explain the sample problems
They were able to do it.
They, the same way as my students
Had fun solving the Ken Ken blocks
Some of there were even very excellent students
They were able to solve the Ken Ken blocks,
and they were able to make them too
At this point, I thought
"The poor children around the world, invite
me!
I will entertain you!"
These two experiences dramatically changed
my way of thinking
I wanted to give classes students from different
countries
I was excited and wondered which students
from what country would come and visit me
next
Which school in what country can I visit next
I waited, and waited, and continued to wait
But nothing happened
I needed a new challenge to let myself grow
I asked myself, what should I do next?
After staying close to Tokyo station at the
center of Japan, where do I go next?
One idea came to mind
New York, Manhattan.
Grand Central staion
In one night, I decided to move my classroom
from Tokyo to Manhattan
It was 5 months after the event
The biggest benefit I gained from Ken Ken
blocks
Is that it brought me to New York
I entered the country with a green card on
February 10th 2015
one month before this, I took an interview
at the U.S.A embassy in Tokyo
The interviewee told me "You have a great
visa."
I had no idea what it meant
When I went home, I researched it
"America Green Card Category E11"
This is what was written
"Extraordinary ability in the science, arts,
education, business, or athletics"
"This is impossible"
I am an ordinary man
I have no talent
This is all thanks to the Ken Ken blocks
I have a dream that I have been nursing since
There is infinite possibilities in the Ken
Ken blocks
Contests to solve the Ken Ken blocks are held
in different places all over the world
The same set of puzzles are distributed to
everyone
With a ready set go, the person who solves
first wins
But this has not satisfied me anymore
Create a puzzle, and exchange it, then solve
I want to make it into a household competition
I continue to think about it
In 2014, I had the opportunity to visit a
Japanese school in New York
They had puzzle contest for each year
We asked the 1st and 2nd place in contest
to create puzzle questions
In creating puzzles, the most important thing
is
There must only be one answer
The problem with 2 or more answers will be
disqualified
Disqualified, disqualified, disqualified
The last class was the 2nd year of middle
school
The 1st place was a girl and the 2nd place
was a boy
1 minute after the girl finished, the boy
finished
The puzzle of the 2 were proper problems that
did not have any other answers
They would exchange this and solve each others
problems
We made the rule so that the girl would have
an upperhand
The girl start first in solving the puzzle
the boy created
And, after a minute, the boy will start solving
the girl made
Since there was a minute difference, I thought
a come-from-behind victory would be impossible
But the boy won
When you try to make a puzzle quickly, it
will become easy
When you try to create it as fast as you can,
it creates risk having more than one answer
It is very fun to make puzzles while thinking
of this
In Shogi and Chess, the size of the board,
and the number of pieces are fixed
But with the Ken Ken blocks, from a 4 by 4
addition
To 9 by 9 with multiplication without an operator
There are different types of different levelled
puzzles
I think this suites the internet very well
You can find an opponent that suites your
level
There is no language barrier which enables
you to compete against anyone in the world
For example, when you continously win against
5 players, you can be promoted to a higher
level
I think this could be a hit around the world
If this becomes popular, the math ability
and cognitive faculty would rapidly increase
It is fundamentally different from time-killing
games
And if possible, I would like to hold a world
tournament once in 4 years
Similar to the soccer world cup
There aren't many people that can join the
soccer world cup
But anyone can join the Ken Ken block
I get excited on my own imagining how popular
this can be
Even surpassing the soccer world cup
I say to many people, "I want to do this,
what do you think?"
But so far no one has fullfilled my dream
I would be extremely happy if someone here
can help me fulfill this dream
I am going to show how Ken Ken blocks are
made
Later on, but before this
I would like to explain what kind of puzzle
Ken Ken block is
This machine has been acting since earlier
This may take time so I might have to talk
about something else
Oh there it is.
Thank you very much
This is a 4 by 4 Ken Ken block
This is a Ken Ken block that is only addition
There are 4 numbers that can be used, 1, 2,
3, 4
The most important rule, the same number appears
once vertically and horizontally
But you can cannot have the same number twice
in the same row and column
For example, 6 here
This small number here, it shows the added
number of the total number of that block
The numbers you can use are 1, 2, 3, 4
Which are the combination that results to
Has anyone asnwered?
You can only use 1, 2, 3, 4
3 and 3 cannot be used
2 and 4, this is addition so it is 2 and 4
At this point, you cannot tell which one is
4 and which one is 2, so we will write it
smaller
Next is this 7
With two it is 7, what is the combination?
3 and 4, yes that's correct
In one of these blocks of 6, since one of
them will have 4 in it
The number on the block above must be
How about here, 4
There is 7 here also, the block above, 3
The block below, 4
Yes, there is 7 here also, the block above,
3, the block below, 4
If there is 3 and there is 4 here, the number
above must be?
Next to it, 4
Next to it, 1
Below, 2
There is also 3, if there is 2 here, the number
at the block above must be?
1, 2, which means what is the number here
Add it together 4, so next to it is?
1, here?
2, here?
1, that makes it complete
A typical math problem is not in anyway entertaining
And you simply write the answer and that is
it
You have to ask someone to check your answer
Or you have to check them yourself
But with this puzzle, the moment you think
and fill in the answer, it is correct
The moment you fill the last block, you can
shout "Done!" and praise yourself
It boosts your self-affirmation
Next, let us see how puzzles are made
First, you come up with the answer
Then you divide the blocks, and create the
problems
When you divide it in this way, 1 plus 2,
plus 3 is 6
You can make 3 here
1 plus 2 plus 1 is 4
3 plus 4 is 7
4 plus 2 is 6
1 plus 2 is 3
3 plus 4 is 7
Here we have 1 puzzle and its answers
Let's erase all the answers, and here is our
puzzle
But this is not the end
We will not see if there is only one answer
to this puzzle
Normally, I would carefully do it on my own
Today, we will introduce a special software
It's a software only I can use
We will input it here
Oh, it's this side
With these 2, 7
With these 3, 4
With these 3, 6
With these 2, 6
With these 2, 7
With these 2, 3
Let's check the answers with this
Why isn't it coming up
Usually this doesn't take much.
Oh, I see, because we still have this
It isn't logged in
On this, one whole puzzle is complete
So, who wants to try making a puzzle
Please, come over here
Here
So, please pick one from here
Yes, please start underneath the camera here
Yes, here
Everyone will be watching while I make it?
Yes, it is quite an experience you won't usually
have
This is a bit embarassing
It's alright
If you do it right and only have one answer
then it won't be
Yeah, that is true, but that would make it
boring
Please make something fun
How should I make it fun
Well, it's more fun when you think about it
How could I do it
Have you ever tried solving this puzzle?
No?
I have never seen anyone create it this boldly
I thought it would make it more interesting
Yes, it is interesting.
It is the first time I have seen it
Thank you
No, it is interesting
Here it is
Let's put it in the software
It is very bold, as might be expected from
Google
With 4 of these is 10
Oh, it disappeared
Why
This, this, please wait, this is 7
This is 7
This is 7, and this is 4, then 13
What happens here?
Does it come up until here?
But it has 7 here
Is this one, this is as one, and then it's
This means 1
This is as one, and then it is 1
Is this as one, and 1?
This is as one, and 1
This is quite unique
This is 13
In the center 5, and the rest 4
It isn't wrong in numbers
Is it right?
Let's check it
Check
Too bad, it was just
a bit more
Please
Please pick one
Yes
Please keep it as a souvenir
Thank you
This, when you get it right the first time,
it is no fun, but thank you for keeping it
interesting
Thank you
But it won't be that interesting
Very interesting
This is 4
This is also 4
I'll have Google line this all up for me.
9, then 9
3 and
So, let's check it
Congratulations
Please return it here
Power Point
Almost every day, I make puzzles
When you count only the Ken Ken blocks
I have probably made over 5,000
It is still fun when I solve my own puzzles
I am determined to spread this around the
world
The Ken Ken puzzle next
There are 3 ways to enjoy the Ken Ken puzzles
The same way as how to enjoy cuisines
The way to enjoy cuisines are, eating them,
cooking them
Cooking them and letting others eat them
The same way goes with puzzles
You can enjoy by solving, by creating
And enjoying by letting others solve those
you created
It is a very fun puzzle
Moreover, it makes one smart
I will repeat, but it is a completely different
dimension
Compared to silly time-killing games
What is most important
Is to use your head to concentrate and think
long and deeply
And the rival is
not someone next to you
But it is you from yesterday
In my book, I actually have published 180
books
I often get asked to autograph my books
And what I always write on there
Is
to improve your personal best
Math is a puzzle
Puzzles are fun
Which means math is fun
It is the best entertainment to train your
brain
For
a happy way of living, for a happy life
Please think on
your own, and give it
all
you got in enjoying trial and error
That
is all, thank you very much